um
okay you sent this to me is there a
setup that we need for this i have the
time stamp we didn't get to it friday
uh it's a tesla motors 2014 shareholder
meeting
do we need any set up or do i just play
are you sure we didn't play this
i never played this positive i i played
i know i played it in a night wave but i
could have sworn we played it on i
haven't i was not played on friday
yeah i haven't even watched it myself um
this is uh yeah there's a
shareholder meeting and um a good old
gentleman his shareholder had some
questions for the for the young tech
billionaire here this 2014
but i think i think we've got something
that might be that might be a good
might work out pretty well
um hi uh roy phillipos
philosopher and entrepreneur from
philadelphia i also
i also played e honda in the street
fighter movie
okay so you know how like you know how
like if somebody starts calling
themselves a philosopher like already
you're right off
on a good foot with them usually right
yeah yeah cause that that shows you
they're not arrogant
hey royce do you know who is your
favorite
historical philosopher who unironically
referred to himself as a philosopher
stalin
but like seriously like there's you
could go back in time and meet any of
the great
[ __ ] scholars and philosophers from
history
and you'd go what do you do for a living
and they'd go well i'm a writer i do
writings
i know one i don't want i don't want
okay i don't want jack handy
jack andy jack handy okay fine but other
than jack candy
the rest of them would go oh i don't
know you know i have these thoughts and
i sort of just diddle them you know i
doodle them down
and uh you got it right the first time
um
i didn't know socrates yeah what do you
oh i'm a diddler and a dabble in writing
even
even even by the way as much as we rip
on and we should rip on
um jordan peterson jordan peterson's
never called himself a philosopher
but that's what i mean nobody does that
uh tesla shall holder um two years ago i
was here
asking you about model s sales and you
had mentioned to me
8 000 as a break-even unit and it seemed
like now
much more better things have occurred
which is good good for all tesla show
holders
a question today is that you had
mentioned that
you're planning to step down from tesla
as a ceo at one point
can you talk more about that and as well
as who would you
want to be the ceo of the company after
you do step down from that position
thank you uh well
you know nobody's ceo of a company
forever i mean eventually
you know they they carry you out um
so you know in my case
uh i mean it is it is quite difficult i
say being the ceo of two companies um
and it was never my intention to to be
ceo i tried to actually
not be a ceo quite hard and remember
guys this was back when he was ceo of
tesla and spacex which he's obviously
not anymore
he's not you know he hated it hey hey
hey
i hate this it's not an official title
but he's also ceo of manipulating
cryptocurrency
yeah you know uh i i would love to step
down from
activities such as sticking my dick an
amber herd and
you know getting my dick sucked by
grimes in a cyber truck
um i've got other things i want to be
yeah right um
eventually it was sort of it was either
that or the company wasn't going to make
it
so or at least i have to give it a try
um
so um you know what i've committed to is
to be ceo of the company through volume
production of the third generation car
so that's you know somewhere in the i
don't know four or
four or five year time frame there you
go um and then okay
these out i'll have to see you know how
how things are going at that point and
whether
uh it's um
you know it's it's you know if if it's
sort of
and now he's having a flame war with
jeff bezos on twitter so he's gonna get
the [ __ ] spit the moon first
exactly now wait for the guys follow-up
question
because it's amazing okay that on a
personal level
you know without getting burnt out
essentially then i'll keep doing it
otherwise i'll probably have to
find someone else but we've got a lot of
time to to sort that out
so you're talking maybe a few years then
pretty much when the volume production
car
comes i i think
i i was yeah certainly be um
co for like say four or five years and
then it's sort of tvd after that
okay and but uh
yeah but that that's the commitment i
made to people
at tesla and also to investors is is
that i'm going to make sure that
we execute through the we heard you all
right get the
um affordable car
and then we will evaluate at that point
okay
just just a quick follow-up um i've been
asking to speak to you now for two years
um to talk to you to tell you that i'm
also a super genius like yourself
uh-oh oh no i don't know
uh-oh oh
mike it's it's very awkward in here
right now i'm gonna have to uh i'm gonna
have to lower it alright
i have to lower the windows in the
beamer hold on
are you okay it's are you all right
royce
are you gonna stay with me here is he is
he serious
he is 110 serious are you serious clark
okay i'm gonna press play i'm gonna try
to get through this
this is for all the tom mcdonald videos
huh now you're getting even okay i see
two years um to talk to you to tell you
that i'm also a super genius like
yourself
okay i'm not sure i'm sure i'm one but
all right
no i'm sorry i'm not i'm just saying
serious this is all to all benefited
tesla shareholders in in the world
i am a capitalist like yourself i am
also level two stage
i've been waiting for ten years now for
someone to give me a second look a full
second look
i don't know what a level two stage is
don't even ask me rice
i don't i'm still trying to figure out
what he's a level two at
oh probably a level two ipo he's
probably had ideas and he's gone through
the first step of an ipo
you know and they probably hasn't gotten
to the second stage of an ipo
i was going to say necromancy but sure
or could be that
or it could be that yeah it could be
that
and if they did they see a very advanced
mind in front of them
is he about to cry well royce it's a big
this is a big moment for him he's about
to ascend
to the next level
well you never took your shot and got
shaky a little bit
i'd rather see just francis pick up
another hooker
oh this gets better though no it can't
mike i just can't believe
royce i promise you you can't be more
he's he hasn't even asked this question
yet
he's just setting himself up wait till
he asks wait till he drops the question
right i can't i can't
i can't i [ __ ] cannot
i'm gonna do it here we go
you today can you give me a second look
thanks um okay i'm not sure what
the second looking i'm not sure where
they're going i would like to come on
board as
vice chairman as tesla
[Laughter]
don't worry royce don't worry it's
yeah okay that's an uncomfortable
question
but at least he's not like to his to his
credit
he understands that they already have a
chairman and a lot of stuff
so he is willing to compromise too now
you know sometimes you
you you'll play um you'll do the you
know the the eric andre will be right
back which is a classic night wave bit
and i do love it
i do have to do something which is the
day wave clip after he says it it's four
seconds but it's worth it here we go
okay i'm not sure what the second
looking
i'm not sure where we're going i would
like to come on board as vice chairman
as tesla
[Laughter]
um hey mike
does elon say yes
well you know cause they already have
the ceo and everything
but but he does but then wait wait
and listen for his counteroffer because
elon goes well no
but watch this guy he's guys he's ready
to go man he's
thinking on his feet he he pivots he
adapts
i feel so awkward dude i i mean i'll
tell you man
we have played a lot of [ __ ] cringe
[ __ ] on this show and i know
responsible for a lot of it this is
the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life and mike i've seen
somebody die
you [ __ ] i'm telling you i gotta
thank aberdeen pumpernickel for this one
i saw this don't feel bad he steals all
my [ __ ] too i saw a brief piece of this
on his show
but it's just a snippet and i went i
have to go find this
i have to go find the well that this
water was drawn from
it wasn't enough the little clip he
played i was like i need to go find the
reservoir this is connected to
the crowd laughing must have made it so
much worse for him
oh god it hurts it hurts but where he is
gonna gotta follow him
i will anymore play another tom mcdonald
video if we don't have to finish
watching this yeah you will so just play
the clip
all right
uh well we don't really have a sherman
spot but
um yeah i mean i i think that's uh
you know i yeah i don't think i'd have
to say
uh no i'm trying sorry it's making elon
even more awkward
elon's befuddled right now he doesn't
know
what to say to this guy well now it's
time for the counteroffer
oh get ready there's a counteroffer yes
of course
is it can we be best friends have you
been physically removed from the
building yet no then it's time to
press it on he should be physically
removed well
until he is
i'm sorry i can also apply for a future
serial position but
at least sorry hold on one second i'm
sorry
i mean he's
that was so bad that yuki had to go pee
um
ceo vice chairman whatever but there is
a third offer at least he's
thinking on his feet there's one more
counter offer coming
okay
give me a second i'm gonna do it i
promise you gotta give me a second here
we go
this is he's so uncomfortable
at least i would like to come on the
board of the directors
oh see what i mean now a spot on the
board of directors
that's that's doable right i
can't bro no now see
the difference being right now
this would be hilarious if you did this
intentionally funny like could you
imagine if you went
like if you went to a shareholders
meeting right
you said everything this guy said word
for word
but not earnestly and you wore something
really
stupid like something that's too formal
like a tuxedo
like imagine if like somebody with a
personality like you or me went to a
shareholder meeting for like google
and wore actual ducks
by the way i'm a bit of a super genius
myself dressing the tux from dumb and
dumber
with like the top hat and the cane and
then you're like listen to me
hear me out on this co-chairman of
alphabet and they're like
sir get out of here and you're like all
right peter ceo all right
fine i'll settle for a spot on the board
of direction directors boys what do you
say
has anyone done any research and
figuring out who this guy is uh i have
royce
and yes the answer to your question is
yes he has a youtube channel
and he's also gonna sue everybody for uh
defamation
for laughing at him for laughing at him
yes correct
so uh why don't you just uh i went ahead
and put it in show
links i don't want to click it i don't
know well you don't have to put anything
just just follow him you know put that
in your little uh pipe and smoke it
i'll check it out right he's gonna get
back at everybody i have a question
uh-huh sure um is this the son of the
bullet ball guy
this is i have bullet ball i have bullet
ball oh my god what
ah now i have to see bullet ball guy
again i got it
trust me i always have that one on deck
i always have that one on deck because
it's one of my favorite
uh oh i'm looking at him right now yeah
he does have a little bit of a
a little bit of us well he took the same
shot
he looks like if bullet ball had like a
son like franquito
from uh it's always sunny all right so
what we're gonna do is it's 50 seconds
and normally i just play the end clip
but this
this guy has has earned the entire
50-second bullet ball treatment
here we go 26 years is a really long
time yes it is
tell me what you have put into this game
over those years
where are you now i quit my job i
decided that
you know 80 percent of inventors take
their
invention to the grave with them and i
decided that that was not going to
happen to me
i've sold all my stuff traded my sob in
for a 92 volvo station wagon with 300
000 miles
sold my wife's wedding ring loaded
everything up
into what i could get in that station
wagon and drove to chicago
if you sold everything what do you have
now
[Music]
i have bullet ball
[Laughter]
so like i mean you want to feel bad for
that guy but it's like
well i mean
what were you thinking oh god
so roy what is it roy phillipos
is it phillipos super genius
he has becoming an investor by roy
phillipos i'm adding okay
uh general society like i mean the most
popular
my favorite is he has a video called
like here's a video where he's talking
about how
he's uh because a lot of his if you go
right like a lot of his stuff now
he's been fixating on like you know the
media narrative so now like he just
blames like white people for all of his
problems
okay and he's like oh crap by the way he
goes yeah i pretty much have uh
investment figured out now so if you
need stock tips like i pretty much
cracked the code of the stock market
and then like six months later there's
another video where he's like i'm suing
everybody for making fun of me on the
internet
and by the way i'm broke
thinking like i thought you cracked the
code on the internet on the
stock market though this is uh
roy phillipos here from philadelphia
uh with another another video here um
this is going to be a video bro i [ __ ]
you not there's a video
from like a year or two ago on his
channel where he's on a treadmill in a
gym and it's like literally working out
and it's him talking about how he's
working out but he's like thinner than
he is in this video
it's like a year before and he's lightly
walking on a treadmill when he's wearing
like a columbia windbreaker
i don't know why it's the most psychotic
thing i've ever seen
but it's him lightly jogging on a
treadmill with a windbreaker on
not even sweating situation of the
public image
my negative public image i guess you can
call this uh negative public image 2.
uh it's april 11th here
uh so in addition to the negative image
um
you know the name has been damaged his
name is
taking money from the major sites um
you know seeking 10 million dollars each
from youtube and reddit
they've been the main distributors uh
false information
uh continued repeat offenders
uh i'm seeking a million dollars from
the independent sites out there
there's various sites out there and
pretty much anyone can set up their own
site
and um and showcase material
i'm also seeking 10 000 from the
individuals who've harassed me defend me
he wants 10 000 for every internet troll
well now we're going to get sued micah
you're [ __ ] happy yeah
yeah that's fine you want to get sued i
don't think i guarantee you
that yeah if he sued us we i guarantee
you he would settle for
uh one of those uh subway cards that has
nine stamps
i could do what i mean i could do what i
did to adrassians give her 50 bucks
and she gave me the rights to play all
her videos to the end of time
so exactly kevin he's got books he's got
books one of his books is
future success learn the truth uh then
another one called future capitalist the
truth for money and success
and the future capitalist a guide to
success
but isn't he broke no not spiritually
because he invested in the books
frozen asian just still being a dick not
spiritually he's not broke
man that was rough dude we played a lot
of cringe that was one of the hardest
[ __ ]
that was [ __ ] rough he literally is
like all right i'll settle for a spot on
the board of directors
of tesla